today's guest is one of the funniest
guys I know he's a you know he's a
beautiful unique fella he you know him
from probably maybe workaholics he have
a famous character on there Montez is
the man and he also has been in a lot of
other series and stuff he has a podcast
of his own called riffin with Griffin
and and he's one of a kind and he's here
today my friend Eric Griffin
[Music]
Spyder you'll have vo water yeah well
you're looking at me Gianni if we just
ordered some hydrogen and oxygen for
Gianni to mix up force ha ha
in between his auditions for like big
movies is here interning what's he doing
no he's in here he's feeling himself you
understand like like so much oh we
should be a centipede how much he feels
myself it's all the hands he's got
unbelievable
yeah anyways I'm here man thanks for
having me
you bet man we uh you know we're happy
to have you here man good to see you
today bro are you I don't even know
what's going on I know nothing's going
on
I know what's going on me you look nice
I'm well you know I said I wanted to
wear my good shirt today for you you
know I just I did it this movie
I do movies to Jionni and and they gave
me all the clothes I was like sure nice
some time I know I know but do you know
what I did today yesterday is like I
don't know if you follow Eddie Bravo oh
yeah yeah ok so Eddie problem I have to
listen him in person sometimes and it's
uh it's Wow ok he put up this poster
this dude okay so the guy is else on
this Instagram so the guy a guy walks
across the street he pulls out a gun to
rob a dude and then the dude Cole Coxon
beats him down and then now this dude
that had the gun is passed out on the
ground like this okay the dude kicks him
in the head like nine times yeah I said
I think that's excessive I know but they
do the guy that now the the victim has
the gun you know he picked the gun up
and he kicked this dude in the head
nine times I just said I think that's
excessive you already won okay but and
then I'm talking about all the comments
are these monsters that follow him I
just like shoot the man yeah they say
like that street justice yeah you know
you know awesome but it's still
excessive it's excessive Street just I
mean here's the thing about street
justice
it's lawless you know it's not but
there's no referee check it out once it
was videotaped it now has a referee
because right in Manatee yeah people
people are now like cuz that guy could
go to jail
yeah like that's the sad part about how
the system works the guy on the ground
can actually sue that guy he could sue
oh really yes I know I tried to rob him
but then he punched me and I'm passed
out and he kicked me 9 times in the head
and now my neck is this is gonna be a
court like this you know I can't even
move my head now your honor you know and
he's gonna he's gonna think dude you
can't even move his arm to put his head
on the bike I promise to tell the truth
the whole truth I just I don't know it's
just the responses are crazy like I like
I'm crazy
everybody's getting on me like I'm like
you know like you have you ever had your
life in danger
that's all I don't know yeah no I did
look man I think well I'm trying to
think say if I walk up on a guy and and
I have a gun and he beats my ass right
the next day I mean I can't say it
really I can't say anything like yeah in
court I could say something with some
[ __ ] attorneys and a bunch of kind
of Muppet [ __ ] but in reality if that
guy to say anything take cuts off both
off I wake up with no arms and legs I
can't be like well dang yeah check it
out I get you but if the cops come to
you cuz they go hey we have this on
video right right at that point you're
like okay well yeah I gotta say
something now let me get something out
of this right if you if you if that's
your vibe if you're like let me get
something out of this thing yes I agree
and I'm not saying it's your vibe but
yeah then you do that you go and get
your deal you know get your Christmas
you know of Christmas let me let me make
tea there it is right there look at it
look at this perfect and let me make
this point to buy a black gentleman no
no I think here we go
I'm just saying getting all the facts oh
wow I like it the voice of racism coming
from the side look at it look at this
POW he cold knocks him out one kick to
the head two three he's angry four five
yeah
oh that guy's almost like up now he's
gonna call the cops six you get it dudes
out dude's gone seven gang
okay now he's gonna get the gun at one
time oh this is like a 48 verse to be
he's got the girl that was cursed Nana
no I think he's just filming for
Instagram actually he should be mine
there's eight okay nine that's too much
Co Co Co that this is what I'm saying
man now use his hat he gets to do - I
think you doing this wait wait wait this
is my point okay this is my point if he
would have kicked the dude in the side
three times I'm with it but that do one
coming - how do we know that dude was
gonna shoot him aside he's truly hated
good but he's trying to kick the Satan
we'll put something in a man okay
he's trying to kick that out of that man
whatever that is in the man's head is
the Lord's work yes the Lord's work my
look man the Lord his wild people think
the Lord lives in a library maybe the
Lord is wild this is when your
800-number pops up and people call to
donate money no but I'm here for the
Lord call the Lord works in mysterious
ways here on Co Vaughn's podcast no
listen if they do would have broke the
guy's hand if he would have stomped his
hand I'm with it you ain't ever gonna
use this hand to steal again okay well
let's go back and watch one more time
and see exactly what kind of occurs and
the gentlemen look a little darker from
the video and they ways could be grainy
footage why do we have to confirm the
dues black or no why does that happen so
people fighting on the Internet is huge
like black people that's not true
there's a lot of white trash out there
fighting it's true it's about 70/30 yeah
who's fighting back fighting in backyard
okay black
finding backyard backyard is ypl if you
want to find the black people fighting
footage you have to look at like those
those officer the officer camera footage
look at this he knocks him out okay not
just two okay one that's the stuff okay
I'm with that I'm done after that one
okay gun after four break I'm done the
stomp kick I'm out
well he don't know how to kick many guys
a book bag on okay okay well he he did
you knock him out dude hey does he know
he's up maybe the guys still talking
[ __ ] no he's not the GU to do this dudes
out man just dudes out don't you ever
wonder what he's saying don't you have
oh yeah that's the one yeah oh that's
the one what is what is in here
you know I mean the guy can't see now
he's out now he's out the dude was out
but the guy might've still been
jabbering like hey I must shoot you next
time you know the problem at all these
videos you don't get audio with them but
I say this you be the guy on the ground
you kicked that man Oh what he's trying
to do is hoop okay go back go back
bro can you go back look not an
Instagram there's no reoww I'm just
saying that Duke you fight that dude
right there but the guy thought he
couldn't they got no no no I gives you
no I listened the guys in the wrong the
guys are criminal he brought a gun to a
to a fistfight you know I'm saying I'm
saying that do did they punched him that
dude is a fighter yeah I mean that was a
solid pop ow and he and that that
knockout punch was real okay so he like
good for him you know what I mean and
what I'm saying is if you have that kind
of skill you're trained you know that
wasn't a lucky punch do have stance he's
like ready to go ready to defend him you
ready to defend them so I can watch it
again okay okay we're not watching it
again there's 600 replies to Eric's
comment yeah okay you read some of them
after the second people are monsters
will you comment it let's see you came
in after just my role after the second
kick to the head this dude is in the
wrong now excessive don't you think wow
this is excessive I'm not saying the do
deserve you designed the dude is in the
wrong wrong yes I do take this man's
like no no okay and so what the other
man did was he try to take half of the
demands life out of him no but I think
he could have taken his life listen if
they do want to take his life he would
have shot him and then took his money
off his dead body but he came at him
with the abuddin oh I did it okay I'm
with you 100%
all I'm saying is I'm just saying that's
excessive
I'm saying like there's no video footage
Judy's in the wrong he's in the wrong
after the second kick man after the
second kick in second you already got
him down get out of there call the cops
he's down he's never getting up you have
the gun in your hand okay how about this
I'll push I'll step back from the second
kick he was wrong after the third kick
the fourth kick on that's too much
eight is when I started a fire because I
wait till my heart fold when my heart
folds that's when I know I'm dumb and I
know when the guys working overtime but
guess who but look at this this man was
walking to school who brought the anger
who brought the violence into the vision
here was this oh I agree
so the whatever's in that man that did
this that man brought it oh I know he
brought two he messed with the wrong
dude obviously so that dude had to give
him a bullets worth how many can how
many kits is that a bullet that's what
you got to figure out how many God that
the Lord just left the studio
okay the Lord's gone now look the Lord
worth bro because that guy's never gonna
do that again PO oh yeah who knows yeah
but that's what some of the comments
some of the commas people like he made
it so he'll never do that again or what
if he comes back and kills and other
stuff all I'm saying is people are
trying to justify right what the guy did
all I'm saying is that justification
just means it was excessive that's all
it's excessive it was a lot yeah I don't
think I would do that I don't think I
would kicks in a bullet let's figure it
out it depends on who's kicking
okay all right if Eddie Bravo was
kicking I guarantee you this if that was
Eddie Bravo okay it would be excessive
yeah
I mean yeah this dude was kicking with a
backpack on he also looked Indian to
meet anybody else get that vibe okay he
wasn't black he didn't look black so
he's definitely lighter than black right
but he's in you know he's headed into
kind of a black direction so he seemed
Indian Jimmy
all right so I'll say this visually I'm
saying
visually now a Indian leg has very
little meat on it you see we've all seen
an Indian leg right if you get hit by an
Indian dude I could work there was
Russell Peters Russell Peters got a
chubby leg right nobody thinking Russell
got muscle they did his name rhymes with
muscle and I've never once might be or
not to view it should be the name should
be wrestle cuz you know what that rhymes
with baby gristle brother look at him
dude oh yeah he doing this is not a good
video he looks fat here why would you
show this video cuz he looks like he is
you were on that did you did you put fat
guy boxing is that what you put in ya
fat Russell Peters box I'm fair to him
right there unfair to what that's him
but yeah but no I love this air man it's
a great thing cuz you're gonna start to
think with all the stuff they keep
coming down on police and like you know
and police are under trained they're not
paid well like sorry you're not getting
the best people doing that you know or
not you're getting people that want to
do the job but you're not probably
getting like people that have maybe you
know some of the most experienced or the
best training or anything like that so
is that as at a certain point the police
who's gonna go do that job anymore you
know what you're saying right now to me
is the root of the problem right now and
I'm so glad you said that how you're
talking about it the problem is not
necessarily the cops the problem started
with who are you choosing to be cops you
know you're not paying them enough it's
a dangerous job their whole motto is get
home yeah that's great if you ever meet
a cop like that this is like a real
model they're like just we need to get
home make sure you get home and I always
say thank God firemen don't feel like
that right you know cuz they get to a
burning building with some kids and help
and they're like we gotta get home
that looks dangerous so sorry I hope it
works out what I'm saying is I feel like
the cops should be trained like Navy
SEALs it should be five years before
you're able to be a cop you know what I
mean
and you you know you train you know and
look talk to any in shape cop you know
what they can't stand fat cops oh yeah
you know and those it was it yet it
called fobs they call those ones that
cause the most trouble
oh dude a fat cop dude look here's the
thing about a fat cop do you say
something to me pop boy yeah but I would
too if listen if a cop is my size I
totally get why they need a gun yeah you
know you think I'm fighting you come at
me I'm like so I get it so I just think
like so they're not and people aren't
leaving like Harvard going like you know
you know what I want to do that I'm
gonna be in LA I want to be in law
enforcement you know out there on the
front I want to be on the front no
they're not doing that so these are
people like they should be cops aren't
paid enough
they're aren't trained enough and
they're not enough of them yeah and if
they fix that problem then the problems
that filter down through there these are
people out there worried about their
life and their safety but what I'm
saying is the jobs dangerous
you knew the job was dangerous when you
took it yeah so no I'm saying yes you
might get shot you might get beat up
that's the job
right right right yeah the job ain't
selling shoes but also you got a UH you
got a put cuffs on somebody like you do
a podcast and you might get shot then
I'd be like okay I get it this [ __ ] is
dangerous yeah see you gotta have a gun
right here somebody come in and you pop
off because people are like man
podcasting is dangerous no so now look I
will say though if I pull out my gun and
you take it from me and kick me eight
times bro I'm okay with not kicks you
know what I'm saying you know what look
no but I love this conversation let's
get back into it
all I'm saying is I'm not gonna kick a
do eight times in the head I'm gonna
kick him in the side I'm gonna break
some ribs
oh you flirt a little break
and then you want to put you you know
I'm putting the tip in yes flirt boys
out there trying to take dude look even
though when these you ever see they take
the guardzilla teased out I get it but
they also does a guy there to step in
and go like you're about to kill him
there was nobody there to tell that guy
I think that ninth kick to the head it
might have it might have done some real
damage and yes I get it people would say
he deserves it
I'm just saying like damn are you just
that kind of monster yeah you know so
I'm not that monster right you know okay
listen let's say if that man had come at
you out of you for how do you what do
you do he would've got my wallet here
you go don't you know get out of here
cuz it's not worth it yeah to me is not
worth it you know I think I think if
that guy was really gonna kill somebody
he would have done like out that's what
I'm saying it would he obviously that he
just messed with the wrong dude cool
yeah that dude that dude was serious
like I'm not a fighter yeah you know I'm
a big dude but I'm not a fighter you
know so yeah if he was a cop you pull
out that piece then oh yeah you know I'm
off right there yeah yeah but it's it I
feel you yes but I wouldn't want to be a
cop because I'd know how dangerous that
job is I wouldn't want to you know do
you feel like people think you're a cop
a lot of times like a plainclothes
officer no nobody would think that
really no you think I'm a plainclothes
officer if I could see you like yeah I'm
also a cop like oh yeah I could see that
I'm like a I'm a retired cop I would
believe that you know see on desk duty
oh you know we can I help you
fill out this paperwork you know I'm
that guy
I'm that guy in the movie or I'd be like
die hard I'd be the dude buying Twinkies
at the UH you know and then the thing
breaks out and I'm like you know we need
backup I'm doing this all the time we do
you backup do you think um cuz uh you
know obviously especially in the past
couple years cops have been under attack
you know they're always like the you
know not only that are they under attack
when they're on their jobs you know
they're in dangerous environment like
you're saying but they get you know
under attack in the media - yeah I agree
I mean I'm not I'm not I'm not anti cop
at all yeah but I do feel like there's
two sides of this and we need to talk
about both things and one of them is
like this is what they signed up for
right they didn't it wasn't it wasn't
government assigned right okay they
weren't like you know the games you
didn't get a thing in the mail said oh
god I gotta be a cop and then oh man so
yeah I'm scared of certain types of
people yeah what I'm like publisher
clear now yeah old dude shows up but it
big thing is you a cop yeah so great
right simply walk it with a see guess
what do you have to be a cop you'd be
like what I don't want to be a cop no no
these people actually you know I had a
friend of mine you hey you do you have
any friends of yours I became calm yep I
got a friend of mine in it as a that is
a car I've had two friends I've become
cops I remember from high school I
wouldn't even see they're necessarily
friends but I remember one guy in
particular I remember him saying like
you know one day I'm gonna be a cop yeah
and all these people they don't know you
know you know he had like a it was like
a revenge job oh wait I think it is for
a lot of people because well first of
all in you know people that interact
with the cops the most it's poor
environment you know I remember the cop
do when I was like growing up the cops
were always around like that you know
somebody's always calling them you know
like people don't know how to
communicate as well there's not much
skill to be able to communicate
there's nobody has their own yard
everybody's all kind of massed together
so that you know the more problems arise
so the cops that be people need the cops
the cops always need to be around so
then there's a lot of people that get to
have grudges with the cops you know so
then you with Authority with authority
yes in the same way that you are with
your parents or your teachers alright
anybody I mean this is just that's just
that's just that's the dynamic right a
lot of people look at cops is like oh
yeah they're Authority right and then
some cops also they get you know a lot
of cops were people that were troubled
or always harassed by cops they end up
becoming cops mm-hmm so now they're like
oh I'm either gonna do the harass and
we're speaking we're speaking about
motivation right now yeah why does
someone want to do something and I think
that that's part of the training process
you know it's like when you go to jury
duty right and then somebody then they
ask questions to you like you know have
you ever whatever and then you with
somebody that's like 'hey i don't like
police or if you said i think all black
people should go to jail if you said
something like that they'd be like oh
thank you mr. Vonn what you were excused
and then they let you back out of the
it should be when you get to the door
they're like you gotta go do this
program right I'm staying they don't
they don't I don't know if they do that
for the cops or not if they asked in
these kind of questions I think that
when somebody comes in to be a cop there
should be a questionnaire to let you
know after you answer these 25 questions
they'll be like yeah I don't think this
person should be a cop right I don't
think they're doing that cuz they need
cops will the racial problem - I think
we're cops a cop so many times cops run
into like black neighborhoods or poor
neighborhoods which in America a lot of
more black neighborhoods like you know
especially in cities and there's a ton
there's a lot of crime there's a crime
so they get used to showing up and
somebody pulls out a gun and shoots
their friend or so I think there's more
of a nervous energy when they pull into
like a black environment I don't think
that that's well here's the thing that
I'm then maybe they shouldn't be pulling
into the black environment the way they
pulling into the back environment well
what are you supposed to slowly leave
letters and stuff and say there's
something like listen when you when
we're talking about being called to come
in the the the army the Navy the Marines
when they they have something called
rules of engagement yeah and rules of
engagement in war they'll tell them hey
don't go into that village and shoot
anybody cuz you're gonna start an
international incident right where the
hell are the rules of engagement with
the police right like with all this
stuff in the news right about this and
then it still was happening I was like
damn is somebody up top good mad about
this yeah like you would think there'd
be some kind of mandate they came down
like listen I don't care what's
happening you make sure that this is a
justified whatever you did right let's
make sure there's no wiggle room or if
eNOS to it and it was still happening so
I don't know I just feel like this is
how the cops are structured how how how
it works that's where I think the
problem is I mean we need the cops you
know the first person that's gonna call
the cops is the same dude that don't
like the cops right he gonna come home
and be like damn it what's wrong
somebody robbed us yeah kopi yeah he's
still gonna call the cops so we have to
have a better relationship you know and
I just yeah I think that's a good point
yeah some better relationship it's like
is it better training yeah what are the
rules of engagement if you show up to a
place in your car
and you're you know like and you're
engaging with somebody you know and
they're they don't like at a certain
point you have to at some point if it's
a criminal if somebody's committing a
criminal act you have to put I guess
physical force when we just leave at a
certain point no no what I'm saying is
this and this is and this might be
unpopular but you know it's like I think
that the criminals need to be the ones
to shoot first yeah okay and listen I
get it but that's the job it's dangerous
yeah you are dealing with listen I
remember working at a school in like we
did these gang member dudes came and was
messing with some one of the kids so
like I had to get in the back of the cop
car with the kid to go identify because
I caught him you know and I'm in the car
listening to the radio and I was like
that's the first time I had like my
respect level for cops went up a
thousand cuz it was like on a radio like
you know suspect after machete my bro
you know you know it's like it was like
all these things were it was like all
this stuff I never remember that machete
it was like suspect has a machete and
he's you know you know it cooped up in
or whatever and then it was like 10 15
of those and I was like damn it's just
these two in this whole area probably
yeah and imagine they get a like anyway
they get out of their car that's why
they probably get out and look around
cuz I like I don't even remember what
they just said on the radio dude if
somebody comes running to me with a
knife I'm thinking I'll get out of cake
or a steak you know and that's my first
thought but it's kind of the loving man
doesn't that is a cake or a steak I love
it
see somebody got a big-ass knife and you
like hold on and say you look you like
an old grandma hold on baby
you got a steak let me go get this cake
for you right this cake let me get that
handling grave for you now man but I
just but even it interesting though it's
it's kind of fascinating it's like
there's a lot of levels to it it's like
you know cops show up in two places that
are violent right or places where
there's been called this there's
something violent happening yeah you
know so they're on alert right there's
probably a lot of people that once they
get there they're like all [ __ ] the cops
that aren't like don't want to pay
attention don't want to listen don't
want to like engage with the cops at all
which probably sets them in more of a
fear fearful mindset not to mention
that they don't have probably a ton of
training dude I remember I went to a
place in not Toccoa Georgia one time
where they train officers and it was
like this simulation room they're like
okay you go in there right they have a
screen that comes on and it plays like
50 different options of when you get
called into a scenario so you get called
in like it was all types of scenarios
one of them is a classroom you get
called in there's six people in class
somebody's smoking a joint in the back
of the classroom right it's like a
college and it looks like that on the
screen you go in and you can talk to the
screen and the people would engage right
so it was really and then also in the
corners of the room they have weapons
that are loaded with these paintballs
but that are plastic right and so if if
some of the scenarios you get [ __ ]
shot at right yeah but here's my thing
right here's I know why they do that
kind of stuff right this reminds me of
that scene in men in black you know
where it was a little girl with the
physics book that's the money shot right
here this justification what I'm saying
is you can't just walk in the room cuz
you think the black dude in the back
smoking a joint well he's the one maybe
he got glaucoma right maybe he got like
you know our terminal cancer and no yeah
he has to do but you don't know that by
just coming in you can't just judge a
book by its cover
right no I agree with that yeah I'm not
man ten buddy Ted Bundy's over here
looking all cute yeah you know I mean
you know saying you come in there like
yeah well you trying to holler cuz you
see Tim Bundy and then he's the one who
wants to eat your [ __ ] you know liver
you understand so yeah he got a little
spice right but if you go get a steak
you know it was just interesting even in
this thing and not even like I don't
even remember like if any of the
students I can't remember what if there
were different races or anything on the
students right but it was interesting to
think like okay one kid is going to call
right one kid is going to you know
somebody comes in the door in the back
like somebody just comes in the door to
drop off notes for the teacher like
there was just so many little things you
were like one kid reaches for his bag
now they play it three times and then on
the video and the kid just pulls a book
out but one time he pulls a gun and it's
just like man how much was going on that
seems like it trains people to go
whoever
we cherish it needs to die yeah and
that's why they do that what kind of
training is that but there's also at a
certain point what more training can you
even have it's like well I'm saying
that's why that's why I'm saying today
that's why you have certain again rules
like a magician what if the dudes just a
magician yeah you know what you do it
with that white dog I don't know man
I just I just feel like maybe then you
shouldn't come in the classroom like
that maybe it should be a thing where
you're like everybody hold your hands up
right you know but you know had a cop
friend and I'm not gonna say too much
about this person but he would tell me
about like you know sometimes that's
cops you and then you in the bad
neighborhoods you get to know some of
the kids and some of them need beatings
right like some of them need like you
know why you in this why did you do this
again yeah you know maybe a quick gut
punch to this kid you know I was a kid
growing up my neighborhood and he was
just uh I'm sure it's bad stuff had
happened to him so you know but he also
he ruined every he ruined so many
people's lives on a daily basis man
right I'm not saying that cops should
have done anything to him but I wouldn't
there's a couple kids like that probably
you know that really need discipline
they needed some distance all needed
some discipline so you're not getting it
at home they're not getting it at school
and they're running around with guns and
they're running around with drugs and
they're running around it's you know
[ __ ] people up at a certain point but
we're talking about the deterioration of
society in poor neighborhoods rights
basically what we're saying because by
the way what you're talking about is if
you you can google youtube so many
instant instant incidents of like you
know sort of wealthy people dealing with
the cops and it's a whole different
experience and they're saying things
they shouldn't say and they're just
going off you know yeah you know I agree
yeah I've been pulled over before yeah
um and I guess it was scary I can
imagine though it is scary for a black
guy I can imagine that it is like I can
imagine it is scarier I could imagine
that for sure well I think it's a bad
sorry - I just want to get this I think
there's a it's we now we always are like
play it can you talk about this in your
acts um we're always paying for this
for the for the previous-generation [ __ ]
yes and it never ends man and it's like
you know like so like you know I think
why sometimes you have more problems or
more stuff in black never get more
poverty right and so you can have more
do when you when people don't have
things there's more crime there's more
trouble there's more not trouble but
there's just more you know uh there's
more I don't even want to say it's
negativity but there's malcontent yeah
there's more malcontents Thank You Nick
that's great there's more issues that go
on right there's more people struggling
to survive and the byproduct of that
sometimes is crime the byproduct of that
it sometimes is uh you know like um
communication that's not like super q no
it's vague you know or so I think you
get cops at going to enough of these
areas and after a while they get
programmed negatively you know they get
negative programming they get like okay
I went to this area four times and and
every time somebody shot their friend or
something and so now that when they even
pull up for a [ __ ] you know
somebody's cat is in a tree they're like
well somebody yeah yeah I'm about to
kill all this cat's friends so nobody
kills this you know it's just I think
there's like a lot of negative
programming but then the the reason that
that's even in that neighborhood is
because you know these because people
didn't have an opportunity to
generations or it's just like we're
always behind the I don't know how we
catch up you know well I mean I I hear
what you're saying but like I don't know
if you ever watch cops oh yeah I watch
it sometime that hurts my feelings I
know what I'm trying to say is there's a
lot of white people on cops yeah okay
there's a lot like there's more white
people on welfare in the country there
oh yeah no I know and minorities right
cuz just perk per capita there's just
more white people United States there's
a lot of poor white people yeah I copped
go into those areas too yeah you know
it's just for some reason we're not
hearing about the unarmed white kid
getting shot and it's probably happening
but we're not hearing about it right we
don't hear but yeah the news doesn't use
it and make that a thing because it
doesn't that's a good point
you don't hear that as much and also I
think black culture has more of a black
cultures mork's they have more they're
more excited about guns but they're
basically they're kind of like nay
you know they I wouldn't say that one
cuz when I'm looking at you know I'm
looking at cops and I see you know
that's a good point I'm just saying is
like the perception that you have is
that because you've said quite a few
times now about the urban areas and
black areas and that kinda and I'm just
saying like I there's a lot of like
though those trailer parks and all that
kind of guns too they got guns to the
point there's meth there's that you know
there's a lot of poor white people in
the country oh yeah and a lot of bad
stuff right but it's for some reason so
the perception against cops is that they
only are treating black people this way
and and black people deserve to be
treated this way that's the perception
and we have to like school crash all
that down and just look at like cuz like
look I when I was a kid I first started
driving and you're black and white so
just my listeners you know I'm very much
definitely mixed yeah yeah yeah I'm next
so it's like me say the n-word at home
or not yeah that's crazy he wants he
wants to be able to say it so bad
but only you only say in certain rooms
that you say it anyway I just it is what
it is I don't I don't like you were
talking about what I am cuz I think
people want to know what you are so they
can know how to hate you right so you
can know what box to put you in but do
you feel that way about me sometimes I
know I joke around about that stuff
sometimes I just think it's like a time
in place you know I mean we're comics I
know you okay and it's like we have like
a you know a push you know there's like
there's a level that we want to push the
envelope you know so it's like that's
such a word that polarizes people so
much that it's like is it even necessary
here cuz even I find myself in certain
situations I'm like ah this is imma
leave this one out
but I have that I have certain jokes on
stage where I feel like oh this is this
is a good time to say this right cuz for
afor effect a certain kind of effect
then there's other times but my thought
is like maybe we should just get rid of
it you know because just because of the
conversation writer brings up it's like
oh let's just let's just get rid of it
before say yeah just because of all this
that you know to me it's like oh you
know but yeah it's like if it hurts
enough people's feelings or even if yeah
yeah you just kind of go okay maybe
especially like you're saying in a
certain way and then if it makes people
like question Oh what is that about then
then you're like I wasn't even worth it
you know so I mean I don't know I mean
that's just I always find like I don't
like when
like when I've seen like upper echelon
white comics find a witty way to put
this in their act yeah and I see that
and I go okay if it makes me think about
that moment I'm not in the act anymore
I'm just thinking about like oh you
crafted that really nicely just so you
could say [ __ ] that's why you did it
you'd be good yeah and I'm just like I
don't think it's I don't I don't believe
that it's necessary all the time you
know what I mean so yeah I don't know
it's all perception
no I love him Anna I love the fact
you're always able to think about you
know I always feel like you you do a
good job of incorporating a lot of this
a lot of like stuff common thoughts or
things that are going on in in the
social world and stuff like that like
you a great job of incorporating in your
act more than anybody I know I feel like
well I appreciate that but I'm trying to
- it's my experience right but you do a
constant job like I always know like
whenever you get up there there's gonna
be something that's kind of a hot topic
that's you're gonna say it's gonna it
may go well or it may not
you know I just think that all these
things that go on the world going on in
the world it just makes us more
thoughtful about what we talked about
cuz I don't want to not talk about these
things right like I don't want to be
censored so I have to say to myself how
can i still talk about these things and
then get my the joke across make people
laugh or make people get my point that
means I have to be way more thoughtful
about how I craft my words how I act
things out so people go I totally get
that if you don't if you know that's our
job yeah you know I mean so like the me
to movement and all the racial divide
that stuff has made us be more
thoughtful
I don't wanna gray I don't want to not
talk about women they're [ __ ]
hilarious
they're 51% of the population yeah so
we're supposed to just not talk about
Auto craziness ain't that a little thing
that they do
somebody's be hurt who our job just
keeps saying they're hilarious and
people start believing in but know what
I feel like we have to have a quota I
mean I'm just I get so tired of like
that that that tweets to the comedy
store line up where the women on the
line up yeah where's that end hug
because then people you were the Indians
yeah where the Mexicans at well it can
go on and on and on you gotta be funny
yeah but everybody needs an opportunity
well then bust your ass and get that
opportunity yeah you telling me that
rich or priming this is he was twenty a
Eddy Merckx so this is some of the
funniest men that ever have ever existed
and their boat and their black men you
you want to talk about George Lopez is a
hilarious entertaining man yeah you know
I'm trying to think even if you go you
know like I mean the list could go on
it's just about who's fun you know Paula
Poundstone Joan Rivers one of the
funniest humans I feel like that's ever
existed that's a Jewish woman you know
where if you just signed a seventy
million dollar Netflix deal yeah yeah
for a new special yeah I mean I I hit up
Adam about that I was like so I should
expect to get bump bump by Eddie Murphy
at the Comedy Store creasing a hoax
that's gonna be great my dream is to
bring him off date right don't you want
to do that on everybody Norbit oh god
guys he hasn't been good lately but I
want to go back to something you said a
minute ago because it really had me
thinking so yeah in my mind a lot of
times I get and I don't know if it's
that the media gets me like that or what
it is I think like you don't think that
how many poor white neighborhoods have
just as many guns as poor black
neighborhoods you know I never I never
really like if you to ask me like oh do
these do people have guns yeah but for
some reason in my perception it could it
be the my own personal history you know
some dangerous white folks when you was
coming up yeah did I was think about
this yesterday man
I uh cuz I went into this no jumper
podcast that they have and that guy you
know and so we talked about a lot of
stuff on there and I was thinking like
yeah I was just as I was scared when I
was growing up
was scared of like I was scared of like
angry black kids and I was scared of
kind of real redneck white kids those
are the two groups that really that I
was constantly in fear of and it was it
was really equal both ways yes because I
just didn't know some of them seemed so
in with their own vibes that it's like
they it was just a risky place for me
and it all could have just been my own
fear maybe there was nothing to be
scared of right right right
but produc you say your perception is
you know I listen I remember being in
Montana at first I've told you story
before but I've been I was in Montana of
doing a you know a leash rebel on
Tribble runs back in a day and I'm in
miles Montana which is like waiting
north you know and it's just like it's
that kind of know mode they call it yeah
yeah it's that kind of town then the
Walmarts the biggest thing in the town
yeah so I'm you know this means other
white comic you know only so white paint
you know but I remember yeah how much
bacon you got on your buddy
I remember after to show this my guy
walks up to me he's a little drunk you
know and I was like no you know I mean
you might have been homosexual there's a
lot of gay men they don't know how to
get into it they think it will punch
each other enough to be tired enough to
lay down really i'ma fight somebody be
like you want to cuddle that's
aggressive I don't know what kind of
fight you been in see that dude they
kick the dude in the head that's what
you should have done we should've lay
down next to dude you know it's snuggled
on his neck it's spooned him don't you
be robbing people hey dumbass what's he
doing out here with a little bullet your
punk ass bullets put the gun in his
mouth how'd that feel but anyway well
this got weird um so the guy says to me
he's like you wanna fight no man I'm
trying to defuse it
cuz now I'm starting to look around and
I'm realizing I'm by myself it's me and
this white comic and we're in a white
town in Montana like literally anything
could happen to me right now so I'm not
trying to be that dude it's like get off
me fool you know I'm like everybody's
gonna be yeah the whole bar stops and
looks you know I mean I'm
Harvie chalk so so then the guy system
you go he got I tried to diffuse I say
wait from man you know hey you know he's
like right right he goes I've had to do
that before I hate that don't you hate
that we have to pander for your safety
that's what I like that I said we from
man you know why are you here you know
he got most of my life man is so funny
you said go on but this is what he said
I'm gonna tell you what I said could you
want to hear that he goes he goes I'm
from New York
you know I said New York what are you
doing here this is it SIG's exact words
to get away from the [ __ ] damn with
the ers on it yeah okay strong could
have been a Z with a set of the s but no
he had to s okay it was strong and so I
looked out of my cell and so he's saying
that just to get a rise out of you he's
seeing how you gonna react yeah so I
went like this I said well good job
looks like you did you know and I was
like okay good job man and then I just I
walked away you know cuz I was like oh
wow this is like this is this is real
yeah this is really I have in my
sheltered life you know middle-class
upbringing you're going to Catholic
school I haven't experienced too much of
this stuff man
yeah actually had great experiences with
the cops yeah you know when I was a
teenager I started driving I literally
got pulled over and got out of my car
right I got out of my car and started
walking towards the cop car like hey
guys cuz I thought what is everything
okay you know but I could tell these two
cops things thankfully we're trained and
they looked at me like Otis he just
stupid yeah you know and anha took me
off to the side like yeah and then even
give me a ticket or anything you know
they were like all right they could
assess like they were like this guy's
not a danger right okay but anyway so I
go tell the the the headliner because I
was featuring at the time for triple O's
I was just starting it was literally my
first time going on the road and the I
tell the headline does white guy and I
you know I said he would just guy just
say it cuz I'm laughing in my head and
he goes what where is he
let's go talk to this guy hey why are
you mad I mean what are you mad about
I'm not mad let's get the [ __ ] out of
here
you know what I mean let's let's leave
bro what do you what are you gonna do
you don't over there cuz I don't got you
back
I don't got your back right now he gonna
turn around it'd be like me and my boy
Eric cut to me running down towards the
Travelodge what are you doing dude she
does a nightmare but anyways I don't
know it's just that's just the
perception that we have is we had if we
could just talk about it you know
because here's the issue - it's like I
can tell as a white guy that you take
some offense to always hearing about
like oh it's the white cops going after
the black kids or you know it's like
white people don't always race this
white people always wrong and it's like
SSO it's a weird place to be in because
I think they're weak that's what
happened with like with me - right it
turns into like we're all men or wrong I
don't mean like I'm lumped in with like
so once a man that were but see that's
there they they have lived through
things right so they've lived through
things and they've had these experiences
so maybe their guard is up and maybe
they have to look in minute hey you
don't understand how it is for me so
that's just that's how we all need to
start talking about how do you feel
about this Theo how do I feel about it
how did the cops feel about it you know
I mean and it's like and then and then
the criminals we got a you know they're
still human beings yeah you know lettuce
I don't really get kicked in the head
nine times true they roll with a gun
stop at eight um no I think it look man
it's it's definitely like yeah I love
when people you know we got to be able
to think and feel around each other you
know and a lot of times and we don't
have to agree yeah and people don't want
it and and and people don't I feel like
that's one thing about podcasting is
it's like it's a place where we can try
our best you know to at least you know
discuss stuff or think about things yeah
that's all we don't got the I agree with
you 100 men I don't have any answers we
don't got the answers we're just talking
about it right now and even if you
disagree with me even if you're like
even if you think like yell man you need
to get more informed or whatever it is
like that I'm trying to that's why we're
talking about this yeah and our
perceptions of things will be different
but yeah I mean I did I mean I have felt
like yeah like poor white people get
under attack you know and like and that
there's no voice for them I mean
especially in Hollywood I wasn't really
like you know yeah that's a good point
white house yeah
I don't know man that guy's rich white
person yeah but more why people
gravitate it like yes he's gonna get he
talk to him nobody talk to my honey and
the other candidate was all like you
know you're deplorable for liking this
guy you can't you go wait wait you're
gonna criticize me and then ask for my
vote [ __ ] please you know I mean yeah
get out of here
and it so it is interesting it's like we
kinda at some point we just have to
think like you know that poor people I
don't care what color they are man I
never looked like I always related to if
somebody was struggling you know if
somebody was having a tough time I felt
like I've always was in tune if somebody
was struggling I didn't care what color
they were but I never looked at like you
know like my black friends or mixed
friends when I was growing up and be
like oh man like you know their feelings
don't matter or if somebody was sharing
any of their feelings like I was always
more in tune to that then I really was
anything else you know you always have
you have that great joke about that too
though about the black friends come
talking about you took all our stuff and
you like where is it yeah we live on the
same street you know I mean I just told
in here's the crazy part now I added an
ending to that joke where it's like
somebody else has both of our [ __ ] right
they got your [ __ ] and they got my [ __ ]
and you're watching us fight over it I
used to have this thing about like how
like I still have cuz I don't have a
great joke about the fart in the
elevator which is one of my favorite
ones man well I had this thing about a
good about like talking about you know
like I still have friends who are like a
little older than me that they come from
an era where every white person will
demand right you know what I mean yeah
you know that's that error you know if
you're like 40 and up yeah you that's
the kind of racism where you like oh you
oh you you you have they're doing that
podcast with the man huh like if I would
tell those crews I'd be like I'm coming
I'm gonna do Theo von
oh you oh you toggle you gonna sit with
the man huh that kind of you see it with
the man and my thing is always like
listen if you on the bus
yeah with a white guy he's not the man
you don't say like if
next to your key if that work there's a
white dude next to your cubicle yeah
that's not the main the man has changed
I think the dis error of some this error
of white people huh they're upset that
they lost their chance to beat a man oh
yeah now I can see some of that it's
like there's like some jealousy of like
the you know of that of that era before
we're like damn I never got that thing
you saying about the elevator is that
exactly it's like you have a joke and
I'm gonna paraphrasing I know you're
right here but it's like you want it's
like you walk in an elevator somebody
farted in there before you like a
generation before you yeah and people
still blaming like you farted yeah
that's why I say I say yeah I say like
you this is how white people now current
young white people feel about racism
it's like being in an elevator where
somebody already farted yeah yeah you
know what I mean and then and then the
elevator opens up and there's some black
people coming in and you're like I
didn't do that that far to be that far
been here for generations I think you
know so it's like I get that it's that
sentiment but you know if you look at
sports sports is an example of like how
long it takes for a society to change
just look at basketball it was all white
right okay how long ago was that
probably 50 years you know what I mean
exactly 50 years and then they let black
people play all right and then they let
black people coach and now they black
people be general managers and now cut
to 50 60 70 years later we have one
black owner right it takes time they
take rights go take a hundred years to
you know to change society maybe we
probably won't be alive to see where
people don't care about race at all you
know I mean cuz aliens will be here and
then we'll have a different fight a
black buddy of mine told me that he
heard that aliens don't like black
people I was like you were like well I
mean not all black people but I mean
here's just the one way just the ones in
unlikeable no III there was just great
HBO show it was like a Twilight Zone
type thing I think
HBO but it was like the aliens came and
aliens put out a message saying like
give us all your black people and if you
do we will I've never heard anything
like that
we will is this a show okay it was and
it was uh it was like we'll clean the
air you know well you know are they
trying to trade to get right and so then
it was like what with society do and
it's like of course in the end of the
show is by people getting on ships ships
it like that you know they did take it
away you know it's like what would you
do in that situation by thinking no
matter what they say give us your fat
girls you know I mean it you know you
know I'm saying like whoever it is but
like when people make things like that
they always like framing it like race
yes okay I'm tired of it but it is what
it is yeah I think it's all I do think a
lot of it is just time and the media
they know it's people most people know
it's gonna take time but the news and
their [ __ ] it they want us to go to war
if you're at war if people are fighting
by something to talk about
yeah dude like I think in the race war
yeah and it feels to me when reality
even when I'm at the Comedy Store now
then but then eight years ago when I got
that it's more there's more diversity as
more people run it is there I think so
yeah I don't know I think so I think
next time you look at the lineup you
might if you start to count you might be
like but a lot of those guys do one they
call any putting a veil this Chris
Tucker calling and putting as a veils in
every week you know like are well let's
see why does it have to be what is my
point about and this is to push back the
other side is that you know why does
like his Martin Lawrence calling and
putting his avails in yeah he does well
he does actually but I'm saying like if
you look at like Netflix specials for
instance okay why does the guys that get
Netflix specials have to be either
ethnic people gotta be international
superstar oh yeah okay [ __ ] oh they
gotta be the most famous black people in
America but then like Joe Schmo white
guy he's gonna give me the opportunity
to be mediocre yeah okay that's all I'm
saying you know look bro i'll be
mediocre on netflix like a lot of it
like like half the white [ __ ]
they got specials on netflix i
be just as mediocre as them now give me
that opportunity yeah you know me but I
have to be like at the top of my game I
gotta be like you know me why and you
better look at it it's even some of the
ladies you better looking female than
half the ladies they gave him two out
there but I know you were male but I'm
just saying but look I got good loot at
me like that
I never ha you don't want the [ __ ] got
a perm comb at home if you could do like
this I don't want to hear you oh it's
already if you if you look like a you a
white chick in a black video gonna be
like a rappers video please put that in
slow-mo what you see is here just it's
like but it's also interesting man I
think [ __ ] everything you know like race
makes things also exciting bro like it's
fun it makes things exciting dude
there's if everybody was the same it all
be boring bro it's nice to have you know
you got a little bit of you know that
people are different it's all gonna end
up probably in a hodgepodge porridge
down the road we're all gonna start
looking like me or it's gonna be a war
ii-era Louise some crazy Wars that start
but I think the wars next time wouldn't
be based on like people won't team up
based on like their ethnicities and
stuff like that next time they'll team
up more based on not even their
religious beliefs but just what they
believe in then maybe in their hearts
and stuff as human religions still there
that's that still religious still a huge
part of it you know I think economics
are gonna be the reason why the war
water you know it's gonna be things like
that it's gonna be resources I mean
probably the next fight yeah you know
then what do you do like you know it's
like the Hat but if we're already gonna
have then have-nots situation right now
angry it's more that than anything else
yeah it's interesting man but also it's
like yeah this is our life this is it
you know and it's yeah it's like this is
it this is the time we got put into an
existence
this is what's going on I know we gonna
look back and be like damn why was I so
worried about that instead of living I
now on we just gotta live go on
vacations like meet people you know what
I mean yeah I just think there's like if
you hate somebody if you took the
opportunity of this person you think you
hate for whatever reason it is if you
took the time to be like hey what's up
like like tell me about you right what's
going on in your world yeah you'd be
surprised you know I don't know if you
know who Larry elder is yeah he's gonna
come on here oh that's great you know
what Larry yelled I was looking at this
it's not a documentary but he was like
this interview thing that he did and
he's like this conservative black
political talk show host type guy right
but he's got a hard stance against black
people he wants my people you know stop
making excuses stop with your victim
mentality and all that stuff right and
you know I used to be like whoa dude a
little harsh what's going on but then I
heard his story right you know his his
father his story about his father how
hard it was for his dad and what his dad
did and and how they didn't talk for ten
years and and how he pushed him to be
better and all this stuff and I
understand that his experience framed
how he feels about the world right and I
think if we took the time to find out
people's experience first and then find
out why they feel the way they feel then
we can make a judgment on what we feel
about them but we just jump quickly to
like racism or calling somebody like
that Uncle Tom yeah you know we jumped
to those conclusions too fast and I just
think that we need to take some time to
really communicate and you would think
that in the social media world that we
now have access to to be able to talk to
people more more frequently and write
directly you would think that we'd be
able to try to do that but instead that
thing is being used as like a way of
like spewing hatred and and and
single-mindedness and closed mindedness
and it's just like it's a shame to me
yeah yeah it's crazy how people can be
that way online and not that and there
but the truth is some of them aren't
even that way in person okay for sure
aren't that way put a lot of cowards out
there like how your coward most of you
and a lot of the like one thing that
podcasting doesn't do which i think is
something that separate separates it as
a news source even than the regular news
media is they don't use tweets and that
kind of thing like they'll look at them
sometimes but they don't you
that is like the basis for an article or
they write two or three people with no
even avatar said something I know so now
suddenly you know Tom Brady can't take
his daughter on a vacation or something
you know like it's just well Twitter's
not as popular as you really as you
really it rose but first of all that's
only like the coastal like these like
elite cities there's also just [ __ ]
they don't even work in Braille like
they have a lot of people that aren't
even worried aren't even doing anything
into sitting there tweet and they just
sitting there causing a ruckus you know
we've got people have said there's some
lady they had the other day showed she
had seven hundred forty thousand tweets
oh my god [ __ ] die okay [ __ ] die and
you got rich people that are [ __ ]
rich started brot that's what I call it
dude you got [ __ ] like Cher and you
got like Cher's rich started yeah dude
yelling at everybody how to control the
border how to do this in that we don't
live there you know I have some ideas
maybe what I think you know a good idea
but what's it like for people that live
right there you're a billionaire you
know they build a bridge to your [ __ ]
joint yeah you ain't living at a place
where the doors to the street okay I
mean when you live in like that yeah
they talked to me about security yeah
Bryan Callen has that thing about that
but it's like that's what you have locks
on your door yeah you know what I mean
and if you had the whole border thing is
like again this I guess is you that it's
like layered that this is the visitor
result of not taking care of business
agreed so this is where we are now right
so what do we do by this now because
nobody wants to definitively say cuz no
even these like pansy liberal [ __ ] are
not gonna be like they're not gonna say
out loud just let everybody in just a
boy just a man you know they're not
saying that they're implying it you know
right it's a lot of implications yeah
cuz it makes him feel justified right oh
I feel that I'm virtue signaling right
now when I you know oh yeah oh the kids
and cages and all this kinda stuff I
don't know what's going on with that I
mean like I hope that that's not like a
continuing you know but it's like hey so
like in the same way that you say it was
street justice just do with the gun
getting kicked in the head nine times
if you breaking the law yeah you
sneaking across illegally with your kid
in yeah then you
here and brought the kid and now we have
to now take care of your kid
take care of you treat you like you know
treat you put you up at the Holiday Inn
what we supposed to do yeah you know me
so that's great that's what that's what
those people think that's how they think
about it and cages you can really you
could say camps you could say there's
never gonna be a comfortable term but
they it's not like they be somebody's
just gonna show up and build you know if
you want to help out Chelsea Handler go
down there and build you know 700
Hampton ends right on the border no
saying do we affect you or something all
those people they have plenty of rooms
in their houses you know you're saying
this less likely you know what that's
what we'll do
hey liberal Hollywood elite that are
complaining about how the kids are being
treated on the border yeah open up your
home yes and let's let you know let's
let two or three families stay and bring
them familia yeah your big house and
help them out you know I think it would
be great no to cut to those people being
like well since you're here yeah the
gardening equipment is over there would
be a great video you send one of those
families to like one of those rich
people's doors and they're gonna think
they're there to work exactly
wouldn't that be a great sketch Pro dude
every sketch will do it we should do a
sketch oh man all we remember when we
went weren't as we weren't as like
famous you know like now you're like you
know you're not famous you but you're
knocking on Rogen's door right now
lera alarming at the way I'm overdoing
is alarming people around the country I
know we with our powers combined we like
a lesbian couple yeah we gotta get why
my lesbian all of a sudden you the other
side
I'm the other side of it I'm the wild
one you have the one that has your [ __ ]
put together you'll get kinda like a
softball coach women's softball oh now
I'm a softball coach cuz on my podcast I
was to help remember haha
my Brad was a butler and when you said
before right Jionni raises man Nick what
did you help yeah I watched it was a
bellhop specifically not Butler now cuz
he be by line you see uh you know what
I'm glad to be here to see the source
this is the source right now this is
like the matrix and you know white dude
in the [ __ ] suit and I'm here like
you telling me the truth right now I'm
going back to Zion do you think do you
think that races at this point if like
racism it can be always do you play all
for sure people are just II I don't
think everybody's racist man I think
people some people are tribal I think
there's a I think there's like a certain
like what racism really is is to like to
have power over people in it and and use
that power to keep people back I agree
not everybody's doing that right you
know someone I don't think a lot of
people are doing that right I think they
are I don't think a lot of it's still
happening man obviously you know but
it's like I think in another two
generations even that probably won't be
happening I think it's some of it is
stuff that's ingrained in people a
little bit some of it comes from bad
experiences they might have had you're
talking about prejudice okay I'll be in
prejudice is pressure from being racist
and I think a lot of people are
prejudiced right you know they have
their they have things about have their
prejudices yes exactly short people
might be like tall people yeah you know
oh yeah chicks with on no money
I don't like young guys that are you
know caring and loving you know I want
that old man with that Brit understand
you could look nobody thinking you and
your grant let me tell you this all
these thoughts out here in LA all right
all these sugar babies alright nobody
thinking you and your granddaddy going a
sushi every week okay nobody buying that
you have pop-pop having a little /a me
but in defense that okay not everybody
is in a situation like that for that
reason
like we're not mid-40s okay right a lot
of the women are trying to survive know
that to get the women these guys in the
mid forties who are not married no kids
let's say you still want to have a kid
mmm-hmm right who are you gonna get me
who's a relationship you gonna start you
ain't gonna start with somebody your age
right that's like going to the pound and
getting a three-legged dog you don't
start with a three-legged dog you know
you if you have a dog and it loses its
leg you keep because you love it yeah
you know you're not getting rid of it
but you ain't open it with the truth you
don't know saying oh yeah you gonna
[ __ ] get that look
you can you know that well bread you go
into the puppy mill he's gonna be
whatever that [ __ ] I'm just saying like
it's not all situations of an older guy
and younger woman is all what the
perception of it is you're right it's
just a matter of biology - you know I
mean if you're somebody that doesn't
want to have kids anymore you decided I
don't want to be a dad I don't think I
want to have kids or maybe I'll adopt
then you could open up your spectrum of
light who you could date then yes you
could find a nice woman you know in her
late 30s early 40s and you like because
they're like they're beautiful they're
out they out there they got money they
taking care of business they know what
they want in bed okay they know how to
have they got the hair yeah they're
clean you know yeah their place is clean
yeah all that kind of stuff they got
they got their thoughts and in order
they know who they are yeah a dream
journal about a bed you know what I'm
saying you know they got their vision
board that's in the closet it never got
fulfilled you don't I mean it's like
they know these are those are vibrant
beautiful women yeah but like if you're
somebody that's like well I still want
to have kids you know I'm not and I'm
not saying a 4000 woman can't have a
healthy kid but like if we talk about
she got in a relationship it's gonna be
risk but I'm sorry and you I gotta talk
about that day one are you 40 you wanna
have a baby right let's go do it
and then maybe maybe I want three kids
if that's the case then you got to start
especially if she got a little cooler
about a table dinner yeah oh maybe a lot
of tomatoes they got that low Igloo
cooler with no how do you feel about
that so what if you met a woman she 38
well first of all my dad was 70 when I
was born so I know he was trying to be a
second family so I really should he was
just trying to he probably was still I'm
trying to tell was your mom almost 32
when I was born so he was still trying
to probably it was a pimp a faint yeah
he just wanted to have more kids here
might be alive no money he just had
games huh do my dad the best thing man
one of the best thing about him he
bought a car off a couple of brothers
that lived in a neighborhood next door
and had these 22s in the back right and
he couldn't even hear so he'd be rolling
around bro listening to NPR with the
craziest bass you've ever heard Paul
horn
it was insane dude people looking at us
like no if you want to be an old dad you
know I don't I don't think so but then
sometimes the crazy party is I have such
a tough time we're now you're gonna be
you're gonna we're already it's too late
we're gonna be old dads no but I'm
talking you gonna go double old but
that's my dad went double Oh but when
your kid is 20 and you like you know
like right now if we had kids I'll be 59
on my kids 20 it's from saying we're
gonna be old yeah Dan oh it's old okay
do you think it's old Johnny's like 14
or sighs it's not that old
right like my dad's like 55 so it's like
kind of in the same yeah but how many
brothers you're Italian you got like 18
brothers and sister has yet to brothers
to your cousins are [ __ ] right now
you know to me it's that kind of Italian
yeah remember in The Godfather
I gotta see some a deleted scene Oh God
for the three they were cousins 59 is
not that old but I don't see you having
a kid in next year so we're back all
right I'll take NICs of Vyasa a
relationship exactly so you not in a
relationship
it's gonna take a couple years before
you decide it's time we have a kid right
so you're gonna be in your 45 you know
to me yeah I could see myself in five
years having a child so mix it it's a
good call um got to interrupt this
episode I got to let you know that this
past weekend is brought to you by
Skillshare and Skillshare it's a it's a
place where skills are being shared with
you it's an online learning community
for create for creators with more than
25,000 classes and design business and
more you'll discover countless ways to
fuel your curiosity creativity and
career so if you have ideas you have
dreams you maybe investigate them a
little you know get a little get an idea
spark it up check in with yourself you
can take classes in social media
marketing mobile photography creative
writing even illustration whether you're
looking to
a new passion start a side hustle or
gain new professional skills Skillshare
is there to keep you learning you want
to learn filmmaking try low-budget
filmmaking tips and tricks for an indie
look that's one of the most popular
courses at Skillshare join the millions
of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for our listeners get 2 months of
Skillshare for free that's right
Skillshare is offering this past weekend
listeners two months of unlimited access
to over 25,000 classes for free to sign
up go to Skillshare dot-com slash Theo
von again go to Skillshare dot-com slash
Theo von to start your two months now
that's Skillshare dot-com slash Theo von
support the podcast get your skills up
and now let's get back to the episode
with mr. Eric Griffin yeah man what do
you think about this uh let's get into
real quick this James Davis thing that
went down Oh what with the girl with the
the young lady had a tweet making fun of
extensions the rapper that got oh he got
killed extensive extensive yeah and that
room yeah James Davis but that's not the
girl but the girl came out of MIDI Joe
oh also James Davis tweeted her about
something no he called James Davis
called out the girl bright as he was the
one that made the joke she was the one
that made the joke right okay I know I
know the joke I've seen I've seen it
I've seen a bit did you think it was
alright um I I thought I got it but you
know what that joke is like what we were
talking about earlier by saying the
n-word right it's one of those things
worse like is this necessary is it
really that funny right cuz like the
structure the structure of the joke I
get it it's hilarious right the point of
the point of the joke is funny dude I
don't know if she executed it the way
like I bet you if I said it it wouldn't
have gotten that that kind of thing
right but so that's important too about
what you look like so this is meek
little white girl
who's making this you know in that kind
of smug liberal way yeah you know
throwing a young deceased mixed boy
under the bus you know mix young many
ways just the way she looks
he got Italian that needed to be part of
she needed to realize but I again I get
I'm not mad at her for making the joke I
get the joke and I think the structure
of the joke is sound I think I think
that it could have been funnier than the
way she did it because I get what she
was trying to say instead of like it's
not the joke ain't about him right
that's what people need to understand
that jokes not about him or even making
fun of him the joke is about carrying
around $50,000 right that's the joke the
joke is like you know instead of
carrying around $50,000 you know use
venmo
yeah that's funny yeah but and so the
fact that the guy was killed because of
the money is a way of emphasizing that
he I'm just intellectualizing to joke
right yeah no now let's say she just
didn't executed in a way that it was
like super funny well it shows you how
young people I think to me it feels like
either like a millennial generation got
more upset about this probably because
they attach everything just to the
person yeah yeah it's like more of the
me culture it's what I'm saying they
don't think right they don't say they
hear they just heard his name and that
means it's Jennifer he's dead and you're
making fun of him and you're doing other
stuff it's like no yeah she was making
fun of people carrying around a lot of
cash right use the venmo app and she
used him as an example he's exactly
right but it just wasn't executed in a
way that was super funny right should we
play it for the audience for yellows
play it
he's a user rapper who was murdered he's
dead down he was he was shot he was on
his way to buy a car with $50,000 in
cash and somebody shot him and took the
money which is very tragic I think also
it would be a very good venmo commercial
I mean that's that's the joke yeah
that's pretty funny
I mean it's unfortunate the guy died it
is but it's like if you tell a joke with
JFK in it bro he's dead
exactly it's like it's like it's like
people people frame this into this thing
to about like it becomes racial it
becomes like you know it becomes about
this why girls like she's Indian yeah
but yeah yeah but she looks white enough
to me but also okay so she's Indian who
who knows that who who's gonna know that
like if she if she wanted to look Indian
she'd look Indian yeah okay so though I
don't want to hear that if I closed my
eyes what do I hear I hear a white girl
okay and that's what people around the
country that they don't know they don't
even know her name and then you add that
element to it so what is that supposed
to mean and that's why I say people want
to know what you are so they can know
how to hate you like I'm all for her not
saying like she shouldn't say what she
is everything it's like no I'm just a
person making a funny joke right you
know but I think she should if I were
Howard I would go even further and I
double down I was not with you I'd be
double barrel I would be the dirt with
Dina Hashem and she makes do jokes that
throat that that are just completely
no-holds-barred that's exactly I would
do and she would have a career for
herself yes she could be the next on who
was the big lady they got skin that all
out of all about no the big lady they
gots thin thin and very low okay she did
the roast Lisa Lampanelli that's who I
meant what she lost all that weight yeah
disappeared bro well ice I don't know
he's like baby Jessica brush she [ __ ]
fell off the face of the earth
bruh so what did James Davis say so he
was just like the first one that kind of
brought the joke to light and was like
this wasn't wrong this is wrong and made
a big stir about it and everybody was
criticizing
for attacking another comment I agree
with that though he could lie games yeah
I like you know James too but I feel
like this is one of these things works
like this is like one of those things
it's like what are we doing right now I
mean if we're gonna like if I'm gonna
criticize her at all it's gonna be like
what cuz I'm not a fan of this type of
comedy this kind of like slow you know
right I like boring that's boring to me
that's not we see that for an hours a
writer yeah but it's a well-crafted joke
I mean kudos you know but it's just like
that's that kind of smug [ __ ] that
Comedy Central wants to put you know you
have to watch that for half hour and be
like you're supposed to be like oh is
this gonna be the next like like I'll
come at ya like funny is not a thing
anymore like I so for some reason it's
not important to be funny or
entertaining like is that entertaining
like like that's the kind of joke where
you see then you're supposed to go like
this oh well done my yeah you know
that's not I want to be like ah good I
want people to be like if you perform
away myself
if you perform it in a certain way
people gonna be like that's [ __ ] up
yeah but they they they they appreciated
what you did that was just more for the
shock value if she's a right way it was
presented I'm saying but I am mad at her
I'm just telling you know what's her
name
Dena Hashim Dena passion putting out
there to you you ain't you did all right
keep doing you yeah you know that's the
chances we have to take yeah and also
yeah and James I mean I've heard from
people in meetings I've heard from
people just on the street that James
Davis is hard to work with I've heard
that repeatedly to the young man it's
hard to work with huh get him on the
podcast yeah I'll have uh love to have
him come on is he saying that I've heard
that I'm not saying that oh he's a bad
guy I'm not saying he's not funny I'm
just saying that that I've heard that I
just wonder hard to say that about you
now they are I don't believe it
but I'll say this you know cos now not
to use the guy now on stage complaining
about it's too loud in the hallway yeah
that's how I knew you changed that's
when you change well the place also
Comedy Store know you change the oh
don't change that with two years ago
that would've been the thing to you were
just powered through
now you up there like a
the whole whatever it's a lot out there
dog you bougie [ __ ] what
happened to you wrote don't say what
happened to you how many story used to
it used to be a lot I used to run a lot
more smoother I think it's gotten
chaotic out there bro last night dude
Joey Diaz on stage though likes [ __ ]
[ __ ] the whole time dude come on it was
[ __ ] before he went up there and it's
like y'all letting this man be up there
with that shitty mic well that's
something they gotta take acid that's a
technical issue but every time the
technician dry he's out back smoking
dope keep working Radio Shack on the off
days I think he knows how to work all
the equipment oh God
see what I'm saying you changed they got
now they got a stool over there where
the guy that by the window he used to
stand up and work now he's sitting over
there milling around brah hey I got
attacked at the Comedy Store so I get I
mean this is I'm just sayin stuff it's
been going on for a long time so I don't
know what to tell you but like a yeah I
think you should have James on I don't
know why I don't know why he did that I
just you know I just I would never I
don't know if I would ever come out
against a joking like this is wrong
right that's what I'm saying - like
where's my mindset then yeah cuz insane
who who's allowed to say what that's not
the business we're in we are not in the
business of censorship right we're in
the business of taking chances and
sometimes when you take those chances
they're gonna go too far and it's gonna
be pushed back like Kathy Griffin yeah
that was a terrible joke
it was terrible and she's now bounced
back she's talking to you but she made a
documentary about everything that's
happened to her she's got a new special
coming out so that's what we have to do
where's this special oh I don't I don't
know probably owe me Netflix or
something like that I'm not sure but
they have I got that what I'm saying
that there's a push back after but don't
be coming out talking about what summer
can or cannot say my criticism is
technique you know what I mean right
but like I get there with the structure
yeah if somebody had a joke I would
never be like oh I might think to myself
oh I don't like that joke or without
exactly but that's how I feel about
things I go I didn't like that that's
not my cup of tea that's not that's how
I look at stuff I don't I don't ever I'm
just never like I just can't man I don't
I wouldn't have said it like that that's
all it is you know I still try to enjoy
people much time I don't ever even
common are we only we don't even usually
talk about this stuff but I thought it
would be interesting you brought it up
you know yeah and watch this know
everybody's been talking about it
recently yeah oh I thought it would be
interesting but it's one of those things
that's gonna blow I'll think about
together it's gonna blow up well it
nobody cares we won't even put the clip
of it so blown over yeah yeah yeah these
people got [ __ ] to say to me yep these
people had Nick are they all white huh
and if you see him is that I see this
man I can't even tell what color he is
this could be a woman this is why I say
about me you don't see color
he only see white people interesting
state what's up eg in TV hope it's going
well Steven from Daytona Beach Florida
here Oh what up Steve I just got a
couple questions Eric Griffin I'm
wondering if you've ever had any formal
singing training because you actually
sound like a really good singer mm-hmm
could you guys do a little improv
singing sesh this guy's gay guys hi okay
they're all hi okay it seems like we are
the world what you got what's your
favorite song we did we are the world
the other night on stage oh you do we
had that dude damn long neck was out
have you seen him on Instagram so damn
long and uh he came on stage and we had
a group we got some diversity up there
and we did the other world you got some
diversity of that I love how you always
recognized look at all this little
person I knew everybody's always talking
about it see you have you have some
feelings about it I like how you got
cools if I said look let's do it let's
make it a part of you feels like you
want to be like why can't it be white is
it okay to be just be white sometimes
this your black half dude blackout
oh wait you as always an issue life
you'll have an issue with anybody will
you in heaven be like what the [ __ ] is
going on up here in heaven man yeah
because I'm sure if they have it is
gonna not be the right stuff the movie
choice is gonna be all wife oh my god
what is this that's my damn lawn man oh
this is him yeah you had him on stage
yeah he came up this is Wow we're second
cousins as long as you like if you were
locked in a bunker with no food for like
like it was like a you thought their
zombie apocalypse was about to start
yeah you went into your bunker but you
didn't have enough food and this is
after they found you like a year later
you've been living off like spam but
there's just one can left and then they
found you you come out you like just
whisk teaching roaches the circus pick
yeah you got roaches traded you and like
you know they do it [ __ ] cabaret what
um was there a question that came in -
we didn't do the song
thank you for the singing compliment you
know we own the oven with the oh I'm
trying to think of a song I could even
say man I'm trying to think of a song
that you a country guy huh I like all
kinds of music man don't don't put me in
don't pigeonhole me oh yeah I don't have
to you don't have to be a diversity song
I see you like in a lot of church music
you know music yeah this little light of
mine yes
bad girl part oh I could see you being
like kind of a fat black girl that maybe
you know is kind of getting her [ __ ]
back together you know and I'm singing
that church now Kezia Church maybe like
on two to seven one of the side
character
two to seven references oh how good was
to two so this is my dissing my dude
right here people don't know about two
to seven it's underrated
well I don't we are not on a sitcom we
should still be cops or something do we
want to be on a sitcom
no that's how much money he making y'all
out here you hear hear I'm bragging
about the money in this in the Theo von
compound I mean right now he literally
got the simpsons person to come and draw
this that's how much money he got orange
people in here bro since we're all
Lawrence bro beige power don't this your
diversity bill burrs wife
black as Hill and me that's a choice
yeah iWhat is bro this is considered
white in here oh there's another black
brother right there
Charlamagne the gat yeah that's
Charlemagne they got this question comes
from Josh he's looking for some advice
from both you Oh Theo Eric pomp the
podcast is going well I have a question
for you both
what's a good way to you know discover
new things in terms of like a career
path or things you might be interested
in that you haven't really found yet cuz
I work a warehouse job and I see my boss
and it's just this wicked fat guy kind
of missing almost all of his hair and I
hope he doesn't watch the old podcast so
you know I guess I just need some advice
on how to find something that I'm more
passionate about okay cut - cut - his
boss bringing him into office hey come
on in just one little work assessment
and then he turns on this so am i the
fact and then they have a real
conversation together finally for the
first exact and they start a business
together
boom I think what you can do buddy
what's the guy's name
Josh Josh I think what you should do is
you know figure out what moves you what
you're passionate about and then like
stay in your car drive uber and lyft for
a little while to make money to make
ends meet
while you're going to you know that
two-year program to be a dentist or or
whatever it is that you want to do you
have to do
most people don't do what they want to
do out of fear you haven't left that job
because you're scared because you're
worried about the things that you have
in your life then you're a slave to your
possessions your slave to your rent and
or that girlfriend that you don't really
love figure out what you want to do in
your life and then go out and do it and
then you find your happiness yeah that's
what you have to do yeah I think look at
there's some good suggestions man if you
at the warehouse and you got the big
boss dude I think what I would do is I
used to work at a warehouse man I didn't
mind that I like some of the smells and
the peacefulness of just the products
sitting there behind the scenes knowing
they were about to go on the big stage
out front you know stage I clearly were
robbing the place - how much stuff did
you take home with you how many boxes
did you open I've been like oh yeah I
will say this one time on one time I
don't work at the grocery I stole a
gross of baby food 144 jars will you out
on the street huh you have a jacket like
you need this baby food you need them
Peas oh um Cara are you eating baby food
yeah dude I tell you this bra oh here we
go
I'm not here's how you know you're not a
pedophile dude after two or three jars I
was over it man okay I don't know if
that's how pedophilia works but but you
know cuz here's the thing if you're a
pedophile you're gonna be cracking into
those drawers forever you know trying to
have a meet you know taking somebody out
to dinner or whatever I just knew after
three jars I was like [ __ ] all of this
man but here's what I would say man yeah
I would have a little bit of a game plan
yeah and you'll move when you're ready
man when you're really really ready to
make a move that's enough yeah but don't
wait till you like you have to snap on
on a fat boss so don't wait till like
you're someone has true if you still
unhappy that you make a bad choice
yeah but yourself up you know start
saving that warehouse money job you know
so you to save it save the money figure
it out like yeah I'm this is my plan
make it a vision board bro yep have a
plan because I will agree sometimes you
build up resentments like I'll sometimes
I won't want to say something I won't
want to talk to somebody about something
then it's been two weeks now I'm angry
at them I'm angry at me that I'm afraid
to make the call and then finally when I
do make the call or have the
conversation it all goes away it took 30
seconds yeah everything was cool
now everybody's quiet in the hallways
yeah yeah man now everybody's quiet in
the hallway so I always say just take it
easy bro take it easy have a little bit
of a plan and be sure that you want to
man maybe you are happy and it's just
part of you telling yourself that you're
not happy you might want to will you
might work there for the next 20 years
and really enjoy it yeah enjoy exactly
like he's it's he has his own judgment
on this job that he's doing yeah he has
his own expectations that he's not loves
working men I loved when I worked at a
behind the scenes at the Del champs bra
I'll be back there at night stacking
nude we used to stack as much toilet
tissue as high as we could bro we could
get to almost 11 rolls one time one on
top of the next just having fun in there
well we had so much fun dude and people
would sleep on top of the stuff and
people would you know we had so much
time you back there all night driving
the forklift and doing forklift jousting
bronzes whatever this is del champs and
they went out of it yeah I wonder why
what do i do champs is gone sounds like
a great company with a good hiring
practices I used to clock in for work
and go home and come back and clock out
the worst this is but look that was not
you work man only two questions we got
no there's some more that was teamwork
teamwork make the dream work but yeah
man I have a little plan or just find
out if you enjoy what you're doing you
might enjoy it sometimes there's all
these personal listening to podcasts a
lot of guys and a lot you know will say
like oh you should like sometimes we
might enjoy what we are doing you know
but I wouldn't build up any resentment
if you're not and I would have a plan if
you're gonna make a move yes have a plan
dude that's how a lot of people with
opioids and stuff start you get a couple
weeks out of work you're chilling and
that's when you like ah [ __ ] I'll have a
pill bruh and then you chill them for
the rest of your life and then you feel
like the only way out is a life a crime
yeah it's like it's like girls that
think like I you know the only way I
have to you know sell my body or I have
to you say damn yeah you know there's
people were gonna be donald's they not
you know yeah there's jobs yeah
and every job should be if you want it
to be should be a mean to the next thing
you know if you have that vision you
know find a career instead of a job yeah
but that's the hard part right in some
people's career could be a family or a
career might be a family - job musters
but might be a side thing you do because
you like being a husband or you like
being a dad or you like being a live at
home son you know a lot of sons living
at home 50 now have you seen how how
hard it is out here on the street
Oh trust me man believe me I don't want
to pay the rent I'm paying I wish I was
at home really yeah but your family
lives in France
don't they France no my mom my mom I
said that just moved back from Spain oh
wow actually living back in California
now Wow so I'm like I'm at the second
bedroom I'm like I feel what is uh
what's your stepdad like he's uh he's
cool dude really nice dude he's a
brilliant a salt-of-the-earth type of
guy we always say that he's gonna get my
mom into heaven oh nice he's gonna be
his plus-one yeah I mean you get to the
gate so you could be like I got a guess
oh [ __ ] they brought miss Griffin yeah
yeah what did you involve you like
that'd be a great name for a teacher
miss Griffin I don't know she was like
she worked at before she retired she
worked in like health and safety so she
was a health and safety specialist are
you used to kind of do you get a lot of
year since the humor from your mom yeah
yeah my mom she thinks she just like me
she thinks she's funnier than she is
yeah
you know what I mean so she like yeah
she like you know cuz my mom right now
I'm dealing with my mom has dementia oh
wow yes I'm dealing with that right now
you know like if she sees this you know
she's right now she's yelling at the
camera they still say it again a half
hour yeah yeah yeah it's crazy but like
other but like she's still sarcastic she
still got says humor like we're in the
doctor's office talking to the doctor
about this and I'm saying things and
she's like he's adopted she just you
know making a joke you know she's like
very funny you know like every time we
talk about this and my mom goes she goes
Erik oh where am I Who am I you know she
makes the joke like like that let that
that's a dementia yeah she's making a
joke about it and I go oh that's funny
ma tell me where you are
she don't know
she say the wrong place she still think
she's his pain you know sweetie that's
what she said the doctor she told the
doctor I miss pain is it kind of scary
to see that it is but at the same time
at the same time it's like this is the
new baseline so I'm not gonna like I
can't be sitting around being like oh my
God my mom you know I just go let me
just enjoy what wait cuz she still it's
crazy because dimensions that kind of
thing we're like everything's fine
except for like these two things right
you know and these two things are like
part of their reality so you just have
to go with it you know that's the hard
part I'm talking about it on stage cuz
that's hard you know relieve all my
stress or anxiety about it but I'm
really not like super depressed about it
I'm just kind of like okay we're just
gonna deal with it and just move forward
yeah did she talk to you about like on a
personal level like that she's scared
about it no because she doesn't my mom's
very stubborn so she doesn't even
realize it she doesn't she knows
something's up and I think she knows
more than she wants to let on right but
it's better to say like you know it's
like for her to be like but she thinks
her grandmother's house is ten minutes
away like a walk you know and instead of
like being like maybe I'm wrong no no
it's she's adamant you know we're gonna
get in the car we driving around 45
minutes you don't know where the hell it
is yeah but she's saying if I could just
find the river
I might ain't a river around here you
know I mean after wilds get upset it's
like where we're at you know they put
some black stem cells in a Justin
Timberlake let's be honest here we go
I've heard this I'm not joking man don't
think a lot of dudes have said first of
all if if they could do that all you
honkies would be doing that but we can't
afford them bro you can afford to make
in it for you people want to be on TV
that could be a stem-cell research room
right over there man that's your stem
cells but we can't afford the good good
stuff from Egypt and that's always it
Egypt well I'm just saying a couple
black guys I talked to at a pizza place
one time at night told me because that's
where science it's done at that pizza
place
they asked where the world problems are
solved saying okay that they told me
there's a same
they heard me that they that they heard
that Justin Timberlake except the
pyramid got black stem cells do you
believe it no that's not a thing I swear
I swear to god man yeah but that's not a
thing
well Flat Earth wasn't a thing and I'll
tell you this about five years ago I was
at a Burger King and a black gentleman
told me this true story another matter
another intellectual hotbed burger at
the Burger King bathroom but here they
always got the scoop you know they got
the word on the street man you know and
so and he told me flat he goes look man
I'm gonna tell you the earth ain't round
bra and I thought he was crazy dude 40
minutes later I thought he was maybe
crazy and then three years later Flat
Earth is a huge thing no it's not a huge
thing Flat Earth it's not a huge thing
huge man his documentaries about it we
don't know where we are right now what
you know and this is where the podcast
goes off the rails we already had our
Sam Tripoli episode so we're good with
the Flat Earth
yeah nobody what are you hearing
anything like that
who'd you just let him talk whenever he
wants we try not to care
we shouldn't if I don't think Sam
tripolis a flat earther but this
[ __ ] should raise his hand like
we asked school I agree okay I don't
want him just talking about a turn like
that bro look tell me about it he's
about to be in that show power they in
he's in power yeah yeah and they're
putting anyone so he tells us about it
every day I been on it though he loves
being a white guy around you know tell
me about it dude he said I told her I
said look bro if you're doing two
seasons of power or you gonna have a
mixed kid in a year yeah does he date
you day black women yeah yeah you know
yeah I do
he just said all this has just texted
him yes I'll make sure you say yesterday
his publicist by the way fine
is she asleep Oh Cassandra what else we
got Nicholas you want some news more
questions yeah let's get a little bit of
news man we got Eric Cooper one of the
funniest guys man did I love watching
you
I think I love watching you too though I
love what we both like watching each
other
oh this so coming to America Adrian
Peterson is reportedly in serious debt
after making over a hundred million
dollars in his career the highest-paid
running back of all time he's being sued
for failure to pay a 5.2 million dollar
loan and he owes almost ten million
dollars to multiple different creditors
and that 5.2 million dollar loan was
just to cover other loans who's it
obviously this is what creditor the zoo
of [ __ ] well this is Washington DC so
look he's on a camel back you can see
the picture this is why he's broke yeah
this is bad decisions right here this is
how you can't just give anybody a
hundred million dollars and think they
don't know what to do with it yeah I
mean you ever seen that 34:30 about all
the broke NFL players
this is why that's why they broke they
doing dumb [ __ ] like that how much does
a camel can look up how much is to rent
a camel yeah and that documentary was
called actually just broke to just there
you go and the picture is in this is a
lot the camera is adrian peterson on top
of a camel yeah or it could be a sick
horse or something can we there any
other pictures of it yeah that's just
ridiculous that's and it's okay I'm not
where is a guy like that gonna get fifty
million dollars you know a camel cost
about fifty five thousand dollars okay
so you can afford a camel if you're him
that's what half a gets it you know
three run in place what are you talking
about the the upkeep of that camel too
though you got to have a camel guy you
don't just have a camel in the backyard
well over there animals is it you don't
know anything about that doing this
picture was specifically from either his
birthday party or his kids birthday
party just right in the myths of the
whole hitting his kid with a switch
thing yeah and he chose to be
photographed like well I'll say this the
media probably cost him a lot of lawyer
money I bet that cost him a ten million
dollars to get so I'm saying I got but
I'm saying your your guy that you were a
running back that's your skill unless he
goes into broadcasting how's he gonna
make that money those creditors they're
done they're stupid well never gonna get
this money back well he's never gonna
get the money but and also you know
sometimes it just takes a generation
sometimes it's a generation or two
there's all its people like there's a
timeline of things it's a learning curve
some people like you know your dad has
to make certain mistakes so you don't
make them you know like his son may
become one of the best hedge fund
managers you don't you just don't know
but sometimes there's like a you know
like maybe this he's the first person in
his family had ever had any money you
know I'm saying this someone's like you
know he influenced people don't get cuz
every time you go in let's get a get to
camel can you give me a camel get that
camel well but they can't like us could
stay in the yard with dogs right they
don't need water or anything no they do
need water
see that's what I'm saying you need a
camel guy that guys on retainer so
there's money for that that's gonna be
30,000 a year yeah I'm saying the cam
will cost money I just I'm just saying
when you you know what everybody should
live as a comic for five years then they
learn how to be frugal to the point cuz
I learned you learned how to like dude I
remember using a blade of a butcher
knife to try to put two packets of
mayonnaise in it a tuna can insane man
we learn how to be broke we know how to
be broke so I'm saying that's the kind
of guy he was poor or whatever I don't
know his story yeah but he just how
about this beautiful man no duh do what
a physique on him I mean dude I am be
honest about real Adana he could do
modeling he could do senior modeling
he's not 75 and he still has one good
year so he's gonna be running out of
debt this year yes that's a man right
there that's a thought boy look at these
folks I want those stem cells I'm
telling you that's what you should do
you should sell his stem cells we don't
think Justin Timberlake got a couple a
peas in for a minute I want to know your
name
I know what this is like for 19.95 get
filled singing all the classics I mean
it was a good time
you remember when the bodyguard
soundtrack hit where were you where
three places I know where I was 911 when
the bodyguard sound and now that I've
been on that now they know they selling
like touring it now they selling tours
to her you know yeah to the bathtub now
oh yeah and her son died in a bathtub
two minutes basically it's like a little
Narnia it's like at the closet in that
line which in the wardrobe that thing
becoming a real half way you leave it
her daughter died it's crazy little
scrunches or whatever the daughters name
was she but the boy the boy seemed I I
don't know man you get caught up in the
drugs but it's crazy
I see how the mother Adair family and
then it went into the kids crazy father
still out there get [ __ ] up sad is sad
do you ever see their show being Bobby
Brown yes that should I how sad was they
took him used to love their partnership
they were on pill the kids want pills
though half the time you checks out that
but they were but the thing is they made
that show themselves so so they're like
in a way they kind of had dementia
because they thought oh this is gonna be
dope we could put this together they
edited it themselves and then they sold
it the way it was and they revealed so
much nonsense about themselves it was
crazy yeah if you see that episode where
when her daughter was alive so you had
Bobby's kids and their kids together you
know so his kids Tommy Davison I think
was one of Bobby's kids buddy they
weren't rich yeah
so one girl she go they go shopping and
she got hundreds yeah she just you know
and they just knew you know I was like
damn why would you do that
Whitney that's messed up why did you go
see your daughter flossing like that to
her
sisters and stuff making them feel bad
she only had hundreds yeah that's crazy
that's crazy man crazy lifestyle we're
at about our 40 oh all right time to get
me on did it take a long time yeah it's
been a long time to you has it yeah cuz
remember back in the day when the
podcast was like whatever he was all
like oh come on now we would have the
honors yeah that wouldn't have me off
Janny handles the book man baby Jarvis
over there Danny yeah oh that's why he
had to get all mine first he was like
yeah see this is something going on here
oh man he's tricky little [ __ ] I
know he's tricky
I didn't even my publicist and then I
was there and I was like you into Eragon
and I look to you and Dane Cook have the
same publicist no I've talked to the
student a parking lot yeah we talked
about it yeah yeah but you yeah exactly
you what are you doing that thing now
I'm booked up for we hooked up until
almost the end I know I know man and I
appreciate you there's no I'm joking I'm
happy for all your success man I love I
love seeing it you know from where it
started to where you're at right now
this is the dream yeah you know I mean
this is what we did do this for so if
one of my homies can do that dream and
break away from the pack like this oh
it's great yeah man it's really great I
started apart I was like I got started
pocket Rifton with Griffith in check
that out R if it was graphic go to River
with Griffith calm or Eric Griffin calm
to see all my dates and all that
[ __ ] how's your experience being
with uh with podcasting it's great I
mean it's a job yeah I mean I don't got
a compound in like a you know a little
gay boy to help me out with you know but
um a twink bro you're thinking with
Lincoln that's we do five dollars you
can meet Gianni bro wait the Licht
winking with Lincoln hit that leak you
know there's just him in a no shirt I
love do
tattooed on his chest no so I'm it's a
slow process I wish out because I
remember like you're on episode 100 or
whatever so I'm gonna episode 40 yeah
gonna me so it's like I'm like damn I
wish you would have done it earlier but
I enjoy it and it's like well you know I
love like being like one away from the
fans and like you know people really I
think they just appear and appreciate
format more than anything else more than
TV shows you know I think movies are
still number one I think if you're in a
movie and it goes whatever people like
oh that's what makes you ask our still
but this is like we have our own tight
audience and it's lucrative and it's fun
and this makes really human and I don't
I don't think I think celebrities kind
of becoming a different type of thing
where I think we're we're just for me so
it's more influenced like who do I want
to let influence my world right now you
know it's like we're called influencers
right yeah I think of it more as like
yeah I think the the idea of celebrity
is some of the greed and stuff that
comes with that or just the idea of what
you are is almost becoming bizarre you
know yeah if we if you say if we
separate ourselves too much from
humanity it's just [ __ ] bizarre dog
you know these people like how many
you've met some like rich celebrities I
do they're not even human beings anymore
and their delusion looks so weird
that's crazy man I just like I know
myself I never want to be like that yeah
like what I'm gonna set I like to like
I'm over with the grips five would be
hey what's up dude to drive the truck
yeah you know these are the real people
oh dude I'm me look I ain't need 200
actors I'm me to one of the girls over
at the soda cart no I'm saying oh man it
appeared when they don't have any
influence or power to say anything a
little more all I'm saying is what
you're saying that a lot I'm just saying
a lot of rumors and I've heard that
aliens and black people aren't getting
along that Justin Timberlake bought a
chips and stem cells
why aren't aliens and black people why
wouldn't they be getting along I could
see it I could see them having some dish
differences but I don't know exactly
well when you know please tell me yeah
are there any black alien hunters do we
know any no cuz I don't know any can we
get when we find one Johnny you know
that like look one up or book one for
the black one for the podcast that's
when the world is finally it's we
finally like racism is gone when black
people start doing dumb white [ __ ] you
know to me that's where like you know
when Fear Factor has all black people on
it we're like okay
racism is Oh
racism over we made it we did it we've
crossed over when you see black people
parachuting in parasailing it's [ __ ]
when you see like a bear and there's a
black guy like get back bear get up when
you that kind of [ __ ] starts happening
we're like oh man the world is a better
place the world is a better place
oh it's not gonna be fun though I don't
think oh one more thing before we get
out of here Theo is thinking about going
to Abu Dhabi and he's a little nervous
and I know you spent oh yeah yeah you
give me to find it you're fine don't
worry about it good bye you recommend it
yeah yeah you're gonna be fine
how many nights should I stay there how
many shows you doing I'm not I'm just
gonna go for the UFC fight that thing
oh I'm considering it anyway I'll just
go like four days three days three days
three nights just go like three nights
that's enough just because of the travel
- it's gonna take you so much time to
get there you got to get acclimated give
yourself a chance to relax it means it's
not a lot going on in that city it's
just a metropolis of like buildings and
stuff like that it's not like there's
like a you know you'll find stuff to do
you know if you're going with a group of
people or something yeah yeah it'll be
fine okay it's gonna be fine dude don't
worry about it Erik girlfriend man one
of the funniest guys I know man thanks
for coming in and spending time with us
today bro riffing with Griffin check it
out and let's do it again soon man yeah
you know well whatever Jionni needs to
be 19 20 21 yeah 20 21 May I think we
have you down oh you're a [ __ ] all y'all
[ __ ]
[Music]
I thought it's gonna take
a little time for me to set that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]